今日は僕のペットTOKARA…
俺日本語の学校行ってくるわ
今日は僕のペット所沢に関する動画です
おいで所沢
はーい
無駄に人気なんですけど
所沢です
なんか、いつもちょっとね
暴力チックにバイオレンスに扱っちゃってごめんね！
なっ！
はいというわけでこの所沢なんですけども、
布団とかね、こういうぬいぐるみってのは
ダニが発生してしまうんです…
ダニ。
小さい細かい虫がね
こういうぬいぐるみ、所沢の体の中にもたくさんいるかもしんないんですよ！
で、この所沢がこのままだと、そのダニに繁殖されちゃって
生命の危機に瀕してしまうかもしれない
こいつこのままじゃ生きていけないかもしれないんだ
ダニっていうのは梅雨の時期ですね
夏の前の梅雨の時期が一番繁殖して
秋ですね
秋になるとその大繁殖したダニがどんどん死んでってポロポロポロポロ落ちてって
アレルギーの原因に
あっなんでこんなとこにたけのこの里あんだ
アレルギーの原因とかになることがあるかもしれないんです（たけのこの里を食べながら力説）
なので今回はちょっとこの所沢を
ダニ駆除
まるごと布団一式用圧縮袋
布団の代わりにこいつを入れます
こいつを圧縮袋に入れて
圧縮します
空気を全部吸い取って
真空状態にして
そこにダニフリーマットを入れると
なんと！
なんとですね！
ようやく所沢もね、このダニの呪縛から解放されるわけなんですよ！
所沢をね、ダニから助けるためにも
省スペースにするためにも
今回は必要なことなんです
それで、まずは所沢を圧縮袋に入れます
ではいこう
無理じゃね？
がんばれ所沢！
お前がこの先生きていくために必要なことなんだ！
今だけの辛抱だ！
入ってくれ…！
ざわさん…
ざわさんこれ入んないと始まらないっすよ
ねえこれまじで無理じゃね？
袋１つだとちょっと厳しそうなので
もう1つ袋を使います
ほっ！
所沢）グオオオオオオオオ
がんばれ！
お、これいけるんじゃね？
すまねえ所沢…
俺もこんなことしたくねえんだ…
でもお前のためでもあるんだ…
わかってくれ！！（大声）
はい、なんとかできました！
こちら
所沢　球体（スフィア）モードです
顔書いといてあげる
（はじめ、許さない…）
はい、こんなことになっちゃった所沢なんですけども、
ここからが大事です
空気を圧縮して真空状態にします
所沢をなるべくなるべく小さくします
そうすることによって省スペースで済むんです
ブイイイイイイン（掃除機発動）
あー待って待ってなんで！！
はいじゃこれで早速所沢を圧縮していきます
ブイイイイイイン（掃除機）
圧縮中…
ところざわあああ(´；ω；`)ｳｩｩ
（はじめ大号泣）
なんて姿になっちまったんだ…
はいというわけで、これでとりあえずは、
ダニを退治する薬も入れて、
真空状態で所沢を保存してあります
彼を多分しばらくこの状況で放置すると
ダニが全部退治されて、
再び健康な所沢が見れると思います
しばらくはこの球体（スフィア）モードで
我慢してもらいます
半分ぐらいの大きさまで小さくなったんで
これもこいつのためなんで
みんな、わかってあげてください
じゃあ引き続き、
所沢、球体（スフィア）モードをよろしくお願いします！
じゃあな！
ウウウウウウウ
グシッグシッ